logan allen will be the indian starting
pitcher tonight he's making uh his
fourth start
the one-two
swing and a miss he struck him out with
a high fast ball
elevated that's what helps when you get
the count uh in your favor when you're
pitching
they're gonna face that guy
the yankees jordan montgomery so
back-to-back walks by montgomery
hernandez goes to second ramirez to
first and friend mill reyes in the
cleanup spot with a southpaw in the
mound
[Music]
hammered deep left field and it's over
the head of clint frazier up against the
wall coming around third and scoring at
cesar hernandez ramirez will stop at
third into second with an rbi double his
friend male reyes and the indians take a
one-nothing lead
rosario just two out of 16 with a runner
in scoring position
chops it and that's going to get a run
home the only play for torres is that
first two-nothing drive eddie has rbi
number 10 on the year the banner will be
ahmed rosario
ground ball in the hole and it gets
through
reyes scores it's another three spot in
the first inning for cleveland
second night in a row they have been
able to put three on the board in the
first frame
yeah but what i like about that a couple
of hits with runners in scoring position
the big man got it started reyes
and then here is ahmed rosario he's
going to find the hole between short and
third with two outs that's even a bigger
knock the tougher hit
that two out base hit so it gets them
their third run
and keep it right on going because
jordan montgomery will not be long for
this game falling behind hitters
here's hicks with one out
high fly ball
left field and deep going back rosario
on the track at the wall
see ya home run aaron hicks yankees on
the board it's 3-1 indians
well good at bat by aaron hicks patient
got out in front
say his second home run of the year but
when you dig yourself a hole and you're
down three nothing that first run can
really liven things up in the in the
dugout so here is rugneto door
deep to right field there it goes
see ya
tie game two-run home run for odor 3-3
and you're starting to get the feeling
that the yankees believe that they can
come back now after last night all of a
sudden you look at the scoreboard tie
game
so here is
jimenez
has a four game hitting streak five for
14.
and there's the ground ball grabbed by
odor the throw to first got him nice
play by rugnet odor don't tell me that
hitting a home run or getting a big hit
doesn't
kind of roll into your defense too
he's having fun two three and four in
the yankees order against logan allen
starting with
giancarlo stanton
that one is drilled deep to left field
there it goes
see ya a bullet home run into the seats
and the yankees lead 4-3 and it's their
first three home run game of the year
you saw the frustration the other night
from stanton and i tell you what uh he's
been hitting a lot of balls hard on the
ground he elevated this one just enough
i'm telling you what
that would have gone through the seat
that was an absolute missile this could
get ugly in a hurry the way the yankees
are starting to swing the bats now
the pits swung on line to right field
coming on sliding as luplow he caught it
throwback to first on a bounce double
play
and jordan luplow may have kept the
indians in this ball game a tremendous
play by luplow and wright cesar
hernandez will lead off for cleveland
4-3 new york leads it
swung on a high bouncer to third leaping
grab by her shella throws across to rob
hernandez
well he says
you're not going to give me a hit i'm
not going to give anybody else a hit
here's stanton
one is driven deep to right center field
there it goes see ya
into the bullpen
two home runs for stanton
four home runs for the yankees and the
yankees lead this one five to three
well again you can only marvel at the
the length of these line drives again
that's not a high fly ball and that's
right off the bat see you later
not too many guys in baseball
ouch
can do this
luplow trying to get it rolling here
against a left-handed pitcher this has
been his bread and butter
smoked down a left-field line
jordan luplow off to the races
and he'll go into second base with a
one-out double and the indians have
their first hit
since ahmed rosario's rbi single with
two outs in the first this could be the
last hitter for montgomery
the old one
and a weak ground ball hit to short it
goes off torres and it goes through odor
and everybody's safe
luplos smartly didn't round third he
stayed right there and so the indians
have new life
so lucas litki comes on to face foreign
strike three
reyes down looking at a breaking ball
and lipke does the job five to three
yankees lead bottom of the eighth chad
green on the pitch for new york jose
ramirez batting left-handed
and a line drive single into center
field for ramirez and he's two for two
and they'll bring the tying run to the
plate here in the eighth
so there you go there's your start
and up comes friend neil reyes who
doubled in a run and scored in the first
has struck out twice since then
up the gut but cut off by torres to odor
on to le mayhew
double play
[Applause]
so he's faced 23 batters he struck out
16 of them he's throwing about as hard
as he's thrown in years
here's roberto perez
the 2-2
did he go
yes he did perez down on strikes doesn't
agree with the call
and the indians are down to their final
out it's the last
and it looks like it will be that's
popped up
sanchez makes the play in the yankees
win five to three
so chapman with a one two three bottom
of the ninth inning and the yankees
trailing three-nothing after one
they win their second game in a row five
to three four home runs two by jean
carlos
and the yankees use a little that bronx
bomber formula to get it done